and so first I want to say just like to
all Muslims going up during that time in
America I am sorry on behalf of America
for the way that you were
[Music]
treated we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah
in the country of Norway click on the
link and donate now for the sake of
Allah subhana
waala brothers and sisters and dear
friends Candice Owens and George enko
who are they one's a ex host with Logan
Paul and the other one is somebody who
works alongside Ben Shapiro at Daily
wire hopefully hopefully it's her ex
colleague how she changed her ways well
here's a video which we're going to
react to which surprisingly from Candace
Owens and I don't know much about Jen
jenko what's his name Jo jenko Jo jenko
I don't know much about him is a
Christian Christian and Candace Owens is
a Christian as well yeah are they
hostile towards Muslims Candace Owens is
part of a group that was hostile let's
see if she change a ways here's the
video as a bank really for these wars is
because Americans don't know anything we
know very after 911 I think about it now
the propaganda to make me afraid of
Muslims I can't even imagine being a
Muslim growing up after 91 in America
because I know how felt about them and I
was I was young I was 11 years old but
that beating every day in our heads that
every Muslim was a terrorist was the
idea that you got I make jokes about it
but like you don't understand like I had
to shave my face to go to airports my
mom would make me shave my face like at
school like I was so young this is
actually funny I had a a mustache in
like the fourth grade and my mom made me
n it cuz she was like you got to like
because it was really really bad cuz
whatever your like the household would
say the kids have no filter so they
would just say whatever they wanted to
me but at a young age I realized that I
myself as a middle eastern was racist
too I was like oh it's not us it's them
and so I would point my finger out of
fear I'm like no no they did it but then
I went to um uh what country did I just
go to sorry um I went to Saudi Arabia
and I don't think I've ever been to a
country that was more hospitable to me
the the love that I got the respect that
I got I literally sat back and I hung
myself out to dra on a podcast I go wow
I was brainwashed I was so scared I
didn't bring her yeah yeah same and and
so first I want to say just like to all
Muslims growing up during my time in
America I am sorry on behalf of America
for the way that you were treated that
it is so unacceptable when I go back and
I reexamine that propaganda that
brainwashing that took place in the
classroom to make me scared of something
I didn't even know what a Muslim was I
remember going to the airport and
someone was a Hindu and I was scared of
like oh my God they going take this off
of his head I thought that was a Muslim
right there was no education about
anything and the reason for that you
know he who controls the textbook
controls the entire country in my view
right it was because everything that we
did responding to 911 should be assessed
as whether or not they were crimes
against humanity we bombed a million
Iraqi civilians we killed a million what
we doing Iraq were on the they just said
there's weapons of mass destruction and
then they never found them but they in
the process they killed a million Iraqi
civilians right and we it made us think
it's okay to just keep bombing Muslims
that that was the purpose to me of that
educational propaganda and brainwashing
is that we we feel nothing for Muslims
if they die so guys you saw that for
yourself I mean I'll be honest with you
like yeah be honest with the people Al I
have to I have to like before you know
like still I'm a bit apprehensive
towards Candace Owens I Don't Like I
said for someone to work with Ben
Shapiro someone a little flipping dirt
back like him a little intellectual was
it Jordan Peterson yeah oh yeah people
like that yeah exactly absolutely
flipping anyways so to see that now she
mentioned something about 911 I can
remember when 911 happened um I was not
a Muslim I can remember myself like at
the end of the day I'll be honest with
you uh where jenko that draw jenko yeah
he mentioned stuff that I kind of
resonated with because I can remember I
used to live at up north Northeast
lincolshire a very very racist town bro
very racist town I used to be called py
they used to call me the nword yeah they
used to call a black friends pis yeah
this is so confusing they called you the
NW and the p word yes they call my black
friend a so just imagine yeah so so
yeah so he was confused as well so the
thing is that I can remember I used to
kind of De associate myself CU I looked
Arab or Muslim or what you want say like
Geor enko was saying yeah and I would
have to be like you know like yeah no
we're not like that Etc and I had the
perception myself I can remember like
like those days I was like oh my gosh
like you know these people I I used to
have a bit of islamophobic Tendencies
you know when looking at them you know
the way they behave abnormal Etc you
know but having Muslim kind of friends
that were're not practicing that was
kind of mellowing me down but deep down
I was like oh my gosh and obviously with
my my dad you know being hostile and the
family that I come from so I kind of
understand and you know what look
they're saying they're apologizing but I
mean can you buy that I mean do you do
you do you buy it bro like I'll be
honest with you because the prophet
peace be upon him said the believer is
not bit from the same place twice and
I'll be honest bro I find it hard I find
it hard to trust yeah the thing is
there's a there's a saying of Malcolm X
in it he says that um they've stabbed us
with the knife they've taken it out 6 in
and they expect us to be grateful
exactly um what you need to do is remove
the knife and heal the wound yeah so if
a person's being um you know vocal
against Islam and they've caused damage
then you need to undo that damage as as
much as as possible now what I've heard
um about daily wire is and again this is
the other side of the coin is that
they're losing a lot of a lot of
subscribers a lot of viewership a lot of
money so it bodess well for them to have
one or two people that are somewhat PR
Muslim somebody even predicted that
maybe Candace Owens might even accept
Islam yeah really about Andrew T coming
back to Christianity yeah so I mean in
it and then the whole point is once
you've got one or two of these people it
makes daily it gives daily wire The Best
of Both Worlds that's why I don't trust
them I I I can't trust him I'm and they
are aah to one another like Allah says
in the qu I'm so sorry you know and
that's why Allah says do not take them
as intimate friends yeah doesn't mean
you can't have them friends but intimate
friends you know if it look why does a
Christian Lobby in America support
zionists who are killing men women
children why because they a to one
another because they're like okay even
though we don't like the Jews for that
matter but still we know we want the day
of judgment to come so Jesus can come
and have his Reign yeah so that's why
they are going and aiding and you know
what's very profound bro like Allah says
in the Quran about the people of the
book I was going to the Apple Store
today I went some guy stopped me and he
was like he came and hugged me he was
like you know what you're doing amazing
job for the Palestinian this I he's a
Muslim and he's like I'm a Christian and
bro he was like he was I'm a Christian
he goes listen what happened in South
Africa he's like he goes listen my
brother bro he was so passionate and
lovely he was like he was like listen
carry on he was us like alham was yes
brother he's like Caron you and your
friends you doing an amazing job don't
bro the guy hugged me like my father he
was like listen Caron they're killing
babies this is cannot be justified AB I
was like oh my good like and I've had
non-muslim a woman in um London Bridge I
went into Holland and Barrett just you
random non Muslim woman me and my dad
watch you yeah and they were like What's
happen going in Palestine bro it's
touched people's hearts so much you
cannot undo the damage Israel you cannot
do the undamaged you cannot do it just
why that's bastard Joseph he's going to
be watch you bastard yeah if you
remember he came in the park on purpose
yeah you what did I say I said thank you
I said thank you cuz you've done a job
for us if we spend billions of pounds to
make a fake propaganda video we could
have not done it and we don't have the
funds yeah they did it for free for us
with their own cameras you know um but
yeah they they've done such a damage
that you know what they they were
unhinged in their approach in their
damage and they continue to do so even
now they continue to spew feels like one
of the officials says and and tries and
is so arrogant that he thinks he can
cancel Ramadan the deluded individual
that it's clearly becoming like unhinged
islamophobic hatred spewing out of their
mouths but what's interesting over here
is look it's appreciative look we're not
ungrateful that that people have
retracted their kind of views but again
we're apprehensive if you're working
with the likes of Ben Shapiro Jordan
peton I mean with all your respect like
if if somebody came out of that or
organization started their own
organization spoke against that U then I
I'd be you know okay all right fair
enough but if a person's still at Daily
wire they they're still kind of with and
being paid from the same thing and the
viewership is going to benefit them I
don't know exactly I mean it's like that
and if you look at this like designers
these are the ones who've been funding
people like Tommy Robinson in the far
right they are the ones that we funded
them BR islamophobia that's what it is
that's why Nick Griffin said you know um
they told it very clearly we don't we
don't there's two things we don't want
to talk about the bankers yes and Israel
simple as that so the point is this and
talk to can own if she wish this or not
for that matter is that just imagine for
a second brothers and sisters yeah
Muslims have been killed massacred in
the millions from Iraq to Afghanistan to
what happened in Bosnia yes to Burma
from Kashmir to Palestine and then we
are the ones that are terrorists you
cannot make this up the ones have being
slaughtered where the ones that's been
slaughtered but Ali they're defending
themselves don't worry let's see if they
defend against the fire
on cuz the fire has a right to defend
itself don't worry when it consumes and
best believe it do you think that God
Almighty the most just is going do you
think it's on the side of Israel do you
really believe let me tell you something
like we know what did but they the
chosen people why are you speaking about
the chosen they are the chosen people
don't worry they are chosen for uh the
fire yes Zionism yeah Zionism they are
chosen for the fire yes let me be honest
they are chos for the fire handpicked
handpicked why because of their
oppression that they did with their own
hands they did this to themselves okay
and we're talking about Zionism because
we even have Jews who free the free
themselves from these scum dirt bags and
you can see how violent they are with
that guy holding a nail thing yeah bro
how about come across one of these guys
man they're acting very brave bro BR
love to come across one of you flipping
midgets bro yeah with a thing towards a
woman and this that with a flipping nail
gun yeah that nail would have gone
somewhere uh where the sun don't shine
if that was me but anyways in a nutshell
guys can this 's apology taken
understandable but we're very
apprehensive and nobody can blame us so
until she comes out and fully um
disassociate associate from this
extremist organization exactly from till
that day me and zishan refused to um
trust her but the apology is accepted
let's see what follows from the From
This Moment The Prophet sallallahu alhi
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana wa tala
Allah will build for him a similar house
in jenah on that day where Allah subhana
T tells us that our books will be given
and every little atom weight of Good
Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a m Allah
you helped you gave towards it and Allah
gives you the reward of as if you built
it donate now guys and do not delay and
share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards